schöne zeit studienzeit lasst uns
darüber noch sprechen ein drittes thema
des tons reif mitgebracht hast wir aber
auch vor den sendungen über unsere
studienzeit versprochen wenn man in
karlsruhe jetzt mehr studiert da ist die
studentenzeit nicht ganz so unbeschwert
wie wir sie vielleicht erlebt baden
württemberg hatte ein relativ hartes
corona regime ist die zeit des täglichen
auftritt von karl lauterbach und der
drohungen ständig neuer wellen schon
weile vorbei und trotzdem es herrscht an
baden-württembergischen universitäten
ein regime wo man aufgefordert wird
seinen impfnachweis zu zeigen seine
genesenen urkunde oder seinen seinen
test und das wird dreimal gemacht dann
kann man exmatrikuliert werden wenn man
dann einen impfnachweis zeigt das ist
für mich so ein klassisches ein
klassischer moment dass sich menschen in
der notstandssituation eingerichtet
haben wenn wir uns klar machen dass wir
80 prozent impfquote haben wie jetzt
kürzlich bekannt geworden ist wenn man
sich klarmacht dass darauf noch die zahl
der gelesenen kommt also auch immun sind
dann geht einfach von so einer
lehrveranstaltung keine gefahr mehr aus
und wenn man will kann man das mit
hygieneregeln auch noch ganz gut
hinkriegen also was soll das und das ist
schon interessant wie wenig widerständig
sich gerade studentische studentisches
leben zeigt gegen diese art von
gesellschaftlichem bevormundung was
sagen es geht insoweit 3 in einem drei
stufen system um da mal ganz kurz ganz
konkret zu werden also beispielsweise
einer hochschule in karlsruhe
also erster verstoß werden wird zwei
wochen ausgeschlossen von der teilnahme
an präsenzunterricht
lehrveranstaltungen da freut sich
vielleicht der eine oder andere noch
weil man so lange zu hause und freut
sich auch mal wieder die anderen zu
sehen und dann geht es weiter und weiter
und bis zu einer exmatrikulation also
wenn man die impfung weiterfahren
vermeidet und sagt ich möchte ihn
verlassen wird man rausgeschmissen aus
der hochschule ja also man muss sich
auch klar machen dass die freiheit von
forschung und lehre ein sehr hohes gut
des artikel 5 des grundgesetzes das
nicht so ohne weiteres vom tisch zu
fegen ist wenn jetzt hier ein crooner
regime angewandt wird als wären wir in
der hohen zeit der pandemie dann
verfehlt das ganz klar das thema und ich
denke eigentlich
das ist ein armutszeugnis ist dass in
deutschland solche regeln immer erst
irgendwo vor einem verwaltungsgericht
geklagt werden müssen weil man dann die
grundsätze angemessen wirksam und auch
zielführend
nachfragen kann vorher
handeln verwaltung offenbar nicht und
das ist eigentlich der eigentlichen
notstand an einer hochschule müsste man
so viel sachverstand haben dass man sagt
wir entscheiden selbst blockieren gefahr
aus und wo geht sie nicht aus und dann
kann man das regeln in berlin ist es zum
teil durch einen wechsel von
videokonferenzen und
präsenzveranstaltungen regelt das
funktioniert prima raus mit ungeimpften
sagen universitäten in baden-württemberg
wollen verhindern dass diejenigen die
sich nicht impfen lassen überhaupt noch
studieren dürfen auch darüber regt sich
heute früh ralf schuler auf der chef des
parlamentsbüros vielen dank für deinen
besuch
[Musik]